so before the interview we were taking a
look at your site and it's excellent
it's AK for screenplays comm and you
have so many interesting parts to it so
we're gonna have some questions with
that one of which is I think something
you wrote where you put in Hollywood
nothing will ever be stronger than a
great story trends come and go stars
rise and fall and studios succeed and
fold but a great story will always be
king and I'm just wondering if you can
talk about you know why story is king
and some of the parts to that well
story is timeless a great script or
great piece of material is timeless it
trends do come and go in film you know
visuals and use of cgi developments with
digital equipment you know all these
things 3d versus 2d now we're getting
the virtual reality but what really
matters is that great story it doesn't
matter how big the budget of a movie is
it doesn't matter if it's in 3d or not
the audience is gonna respond if it's a
great movie if it's a great story
so a great piece of material can really
blow away everything you know like think
about an actor they're gonna go through
various levels of popularity they may be
hot right now or not but a great script
is always going to be a great script so
that's really the only currency in
Hollywood that really means something
you know nobody knows anything as
William Goldman famously said about
Hollywood and look at there's been a
number of movies this year as any year
with big stars that bomb and probably a
big reason is the material you know it's
not just that the stars are hot this
year passengers with basically the two
hottest stars in the world Chris Pratt
and Jennifer Lawrence came out and it
totally bombed and I had her I haven't
seen it but I've heard from some people
liked and some people didn't but there
was a lot wrong apparently with the
script with the structure of the film
with just the story in general just the
story didn't grab
and it didn't matter how big the stars
were in that role so it's really the
only currency that you have especially
for writers it's the your only currency
is your material is your spec script
whether it's a spec pilot for a TV
series or a spec feature yeah I find
that so interesting that you know yes
story is king but the writer gets so
little credit and is often not even
brought in on set and so many changes
were made unbeknownst to them so I find
that fascinating but it really does come
down to that story because then he
talked about being a script reader and
that there were a few stories that you
still remember to this day and and how
whether they pulled it your own sort of
heartstrings or whatever it was that
story really does stay with you can you
think of some films that you you've know
even from a child that just really
stayed with you and maybe they didn't
have huge stars attached maybe they did
well we're talking about a class I just
got two movies on blu-ray that I hadn't
had on blu-ray I just ordered from
Amazon and they are minority Minority
Report and The Wizard of Oz oh the
Wizard of Oz is one of my favorite
movies of all time it's a classic and
but I primarily got it because I wanted
to show it to my nieces and nephews you
know someday if they're we're all
together for Christmas or something I
want to make sure that they see it they
probably will see at some point but just
in case they haven't seen it or even if
they had and it's Christmas and we're
looking for something family-friendly
and I wanted it on blu-ray I wanted in
the best quality possible and it's just
it's timeless it's never going to not be
great so right there it's a generational
thing I want to pass this on to the next
generation now I don't know how old they
have to be before I can show them
Goodfellas you know or if they'll ever
like Goodfellas but I would love to see
if they like Goodfellas someday or
Raiders of the Lost Ark you know sure
well wait till College yeah yeah maybe
you